in 604 2 we're going to be pretty
concerned with proofs and try to help
you learn how to do rudimentary proofs
and not be afraid of them most important
skill in some ways is the ability to
distinguish a very plausible argument
that might not be totally right from a
proof which is totally like that's an
important skill and it's a basic
understanding of what math is it's that
distinction between knowing when a thing
is mathematically absolutely unarguable
in and inevitable as opposed to
something that's just very likely it's
interesting physicists by and large do a
lot of math and they tend not to worry
so much about proofs but all the
theoreticians and the mathematicians are
in agreement that that you don't really
understand the subject until you know
how to prove the basic facts
pragmatically the value of proofs is
that there's an awful lot of content in
this subject and in many other
mathematical subjects and if your only
way to figure out what the exact details
are is memorization you're going to get
lost most of these rules and theorems
that we prove I can never remember them
exactly but I know how to prove them so
I can debug them like that in exactly
right so let's begin by looking at some
just examples of pros before we started
yet try to get abstract about what they
are and we'll look at a famous theorem
that you've all seen from early on in
high school the Pythagorean theorem it
says that if I have a right triangle
with sides a and B and hypotenuse C then
there's a relationship between the a B
and C namely that a squared plus B
squared equals C squared
now this is as I said completely
familiar but is it obvious well every
once in a while students say it's
obvious but what I think they really
mean is that it's familiar it's not
obvious part of the argument for the
fact that it's not obvious is that for
thousands of years cables kept feeling
the need to prove it in order to be sure
that it's true and explain why it's true
there's a citation in the notes of a
website devoted to collecting
Pythagorean theorem proofs there's over
a hundred of them including one by a
former president of the United States so
let's look at one of my favorite proofs
of the Pythagorean theorem and it goes
this way
there are four triangles that are all
the same size four copies of this ABC
triangle which we've put in different
colors to distinguish them and a square
which for the moment is of unknown size
and the proof of the Pythagorean theorem
is going to consist of taking these four
shapes and reassembling them so that
they form a C by C square first and then
finding a second arrangement so that
they form two squares in a by a square
and a B by B Square then by the theorem
of conservation of paper or conservation
of area it has to be that the the C by C
area is the same as the a by a plus B by
B area and so a squared plus B squared
is equal to C squared well let's look at
those rearrangements and probably you
should take a moment to try it yourself
before I pop the solution up but there's
the solution to the first one it's the
easier of the two this is the C by C
arrangement the hint is that if it's
going to be C by C you don't have a lot
of choice except to put these CC long
hypotenuse is on the outside and then
it's a matter of just filling the the
triangles around so they fit together
and you discover there's a square in the
middle and that's just where that extra
square that is provided will fit also
this enables you to figure out the
dimensions of the square R because if
you look at it this is a B side we're
letting du be the longer of the two
sides of the triangle and this is the a
side the shorter side of another
triangle so what's left here has to be B
minus a so now we know that it's a B
minus a by B minus a square from this
arrangement and that's what we've like
indicated here
now the next arrangement is the
following we're going to take the two
the two of the triangles and form a
rectangle and other two triangles form a
rectangle wind them up in this way and
fit the
B minus a by P minus a square there now
where are the two squares well I didn't
say that the a by a and B by B squared
needed to be separate in fact they're
not they're attached but where are they
well let's look at this a line how long
is it well it's a plus B minus a long
which means that it's be long and
suddenly there's a B and there's a B and
I've got a B by B rectangle right there
but wait a second here's a B minus a and
it's lined up against a B side so if I
look at what's left its B minus B minus
a it tells me that that little piece is
a and so sure enough when I add this
hidden lines conceptual line to separate
the two squares this parts a by a and
that parts B by B and we've proved the
Pythagorean theorem so what about this
proof it's really very elegant and it's
absolutely correct and I hope it's kind
of convincing and so this is a wonderful
case of a proof by picture that really
works in this case but unfortunately
proof by pictures worried mathematicians
and illegitimately worrisome because
there's lots of hidden assumptions and
exercise that you can go through is to
go back and think about all of the
geometric information that's kind of
being taken for granted in this picture
like over here how do we know that that
was a right angle that this thing was a
rectangle if we needed that to be a
right angle because we were claiming
this was a square well how do we know
that that was a rectangle well the
answers are obvious we're using the fact
that the that the complementary angles
of a right triangle sum to 90 degrees
because the angles of a triangle in
general sum to 180 degrees we're using
that a bunch of other places where
you're also using the fact that this is
a straight line which may or may not be
obvious but it's true and that's why
it's safe to add those distances to
figure out what it was my point is that
there were really a whole lot of hidden
assumptions in the diagram that it's
easy to overlook and be fooled by so let
me show you an example of getting
by a proof by diagram and here's how to
get infinitely rich let's imagine that I
have a 10 by 11 piece of gold foil nice
actually they could be slabs of gold but
but let's think of this as a rectangular
shape is made out gold and it's going to
be rectangles those are right angles
there and what I'm going to do is mark
off the corners I'm going to mark off a
length down of one and then I'm going to
mark off a length of one so that and and
shift it so that it touches the diagonal
and do the same thing in this lower
corner and now let's just shift these
shapes on the top one going Southwest in
that and the second one going northeast
and what I wind up with is this picture
so that I've now got those little red
triangles protruding above the shape
okay cool
well what do we know um this is now side
ten because I've subtracted one from its
length here um and this is side eleven
because that used to be ten not added
one to its length of that there so
that's cool because now what I can do is
take those protruding triangles out and
they'll form a little one-by-one
rectangle or square and suddenly I have
this little bit of gold that's extra but
look what's here it's a 10 by 11
rectangular shape of gold foil again so
I just rotate this by 90 degrees and I
start all over again I can keep
generating these little one-by-one
shapes of gold foil forever I can get
infinitely rich okay well there's
something wrong with that it's violating
all kinds of confrim conservation
principles not to mention that it would
undermine the price of gold so what's
the bug well um if you probably can spot
this but maybe you've been fooled what's
going on is there's an implicit
assumption that those little triangles
that I cut off were right triangles and
that this line that I claimed was love
length 11 was a straight line and it's
not those triangles are a
have two sides that are of length one
there isosceles triangles but they're
lying up against a diagonal that's not
45 degrees and so they're not right
triangles and that line isn't straight
and 10 and 11 we're close enough that it
wasn't visually obvious so this is a way
to simply put one over on you with a
proof by picture and if I have been
asked to justify how do I know it's a
straight line that bug would have
emerged but you're not likely to notice
that if it isn't visually obvious which
is why we worry about some of these
proof bite